this video is sponsored by raycon in the
wake of the latest Pokemon Generation
being released earlier this week I
noticed this image going viral on
Twitter and it caused chaos in the
comments down below the image in
question claims to demonstrate the
differences between generation 1's more
realistic and detailed Pokemon design
philosophy and the newly released and
somewhat smoother generation 9. within
which it also presents possible smooth
for more modern designs for Generation
ones
or Pokemon like Krabby Pidgey and Vulpix
however while this post suggests that
modern Pokemon designs have trended in a
more geometrically simple Direction
there are plenty and let me emphasize
of exceptions to this proposition with
plenty of even more simple examples
stemming from generation 1's catalog
with the likes of Oddish grimer book
ditto and Voltorb to name but a few I
mean folks are getting angry at the idea
of there being a flamingo Pokemon in
generation 9 that's just a flamingo but
guys let's face it gen 1 had seal and
dugong and Evie and horsey and Pidgey
and okay you get the point these are
hardly standouts in design Mastery I
mean crabby is just a crap and Snorlax
is just a bunch of circles despite this
however the image that went viral
fascinated me people have been fighting
over what makes Pokemon look like
Pokemon for over a decade now and having
failed to figure out a solution in my
previous video I mean that video was
awful I took this as a sign that I
should give it another shot this time I
would succeed this time I would try to
get to the bottom of what exactly was
the difference between generation 1's
pocket monsters and the latest designs
to be added to the now overflowing
catalog of modern Pokemon and to do this
I started to look at Pokemon hundreds of
Pokemon over a thousand Pokemon all in
the name of Science and today I would
like to report my findings while getting
some Iris on board to help me redraw
some of the most modern designs as if
they were drawn by Ken sugamori himself
during the 90s but in order to do that I
need to assemble some trustworthy
artists and as it turns out the person I
saw sharing this post originally wasn't
the original artist behind the image in
question but is a fantastic Iris into
and of herself and has even worked on
the modern remake of Animaniacs which
probably means she's a little
overqualified for this job needless to
say I was happy to see Ashley join the
team however I knew that in order for
this video to become a reality I needed
to find the artist behind this image and
let me tell you they were way way more
difficult to find than you might think
as I discovered this wasn't the only
time this image caught fire online for
over two hours I scoured the deepest
darkest recesses of the web for evidence
of this artist all to no avail I tried
Google image search which led me to
useless areas of Pinterest deviantART
and Reddit posts from one year ago three
years ago and as many as six years ago
in some cases we were dealing with a
very old post indeed and eventually the
trail ran cold when my final clue led me
into the Pokemon section of none other
than 4chan
which meant that it was possible in
theory that the original artist posted
this artwork anonymously and so defeated
as a last-ditch effort I placed the
bounty on the head of this artist in
question and challenged those that
followed me on Twitter to seek them out
and I kid you not within like 10 minutes
they found them simply because they had
referenced an image and a tweet claiming
to be the artist some time ago in other
words we found them and with that Vivint
art joined the crew meaning it was time
to redraw some Modern Pokemon and answer
the question what makes genuine Pokemon
look like gen one poke and when does a
Pokemon stop looking like a Pokemon
these are really difficult somewhat
philosophical questions to answer and
maybe more complicated than you might
think for instance take this drawing of
rookie D from gen 8 drawn by Ashley the
reason I chose rookie D to start off
this video with is that it isn't really
what many would assume might be
considered as an offender of breaking
some sort of styling conventions and
truth be told as a fan of some of the
earlier generations of Pokemon I really
like rookie D I think he's cute and has
a bit of edge to him too however in
searching for the answer to my question
why are people arguing about the current
generation designs I thought this might
be an interesting area to kick off a
search you might notice from the
beginning that Ashley has opted to
fundamentally change the shape of rookie
D to match the other two first forms and
shapes of Pidgey and Spiro in addition
to that following the philosophy she
offers rookie D more pronounced Talons
greater detail to the feathers and makes
certain layers like the black feathers
on the chest less of a geometric shape
on the man's chest but instead its own
collection of feathers itself layered on
top however these choices while grade
weren't necessarily the most interesting
to me as you can see from the color of
the shapes used while there are clear
differences most of these attributes are
more detailed renderings of attributes
that exist in the modern durations these
changes while I'm sure they are the most
noticeable aren't necessarily the most
interesting change in my estimation
because I missed all of these sort of
stylistic changes there was one aspect
of the rookie D design that we had to
fundamentally change the eyes alright
that's a good start
this time let's take a look at something
that just came out let's tackle our
first generation 9 starter Fuego with
way Coco Ashley decided to revise the
shape of this little guy just a tad
taking inspiration from characters like
Charmander and Tony Dial and truthfully
I think she does an amazing job with
this one speaking on the drawing process
she said I wanted to keep him as
friend-shaped as possible and took
inspiration from both tolodile and
charmand early on when I first saw the
design I always thought his evolutionary
path was going to be more hot pepper
themed and while that did really pan out
I wanted to bring that theme back as it
fit him really well I also adjusted his
face to appear more as a mask or skull
instead of just a barking again as
examined with older Pokemon designs I
tweaked the proportions for a larger
body and slightly smaller head and I
think the finished results look honestly
amazingly faithful to the classic look
amazing work Ashley and fittingly I
think next should be this little guy's
final form skeleturge from a design
standpoint I think offers a lot to look
at concerning modern Pokemon designs
though it is difficult to fully
understand given there's very little
official artwork for this character out
now as of making this video however I
think Vivint does an incredible job with
this one though taking elements from the
current designs and reimagining and
repurposing them to more closely
resemble the classic aesthetic however I
think one of the coolest aspects from
the modern designs came from the shape
of the firebird on the snout of this
Croc obviously taking inspiration from
real life Birds hanging out on the
mouths of crocodiles in the wild but an
aspect that really makes this field gen
1 I think are the shapes used for the
fire itself with vivid's interpretation
taking a much more angular look to them
couple that with a terrific color scheme
and you have for yourself one
brilliantly fun design exceptional work
Vivint this looks awesome but let's keep
the ball rolling with these starters and
take a look at Ashley's redesign of
sprigatito thankfully for this kind of
Pokemon design there are a lot of other
characters one can take inspiration from
Pokemon such as Meowth Persian and Eevee
in her approach actually decides to
reduce the size of the head from the
original considerably changing the eye
shape and pupil design 2 offered greater
detail to the feet and most obviously
having taken inspiration from Evie she
fluffed up and accentuated the fur on
sprigato itself resulting in one of the
best looking reimaginings I've seen
fantastic work
[Music]
the holidays are upon us and with that
comes the stress of what to buy our
loved ones thankfully raycon has made
this easy with holiday gift guides for
everyone I'm a huge fan of the everyday
earbuds personally and often use them
for listening to podcasts while working
but they're also just as great for
exercise and walking your dog regardless
of whether you pick up their earbuds
headphones or speakers they offer
premium sound useful features and almost
custom comfortable fit best of all some
offerings have up to 54 hours of battery
life the speakers are definitely a great
choice over the holidays if you're
someone who loves to party while they
sound fantastic what really makes them
attractive this season is their price at
half the price of other premium audio
Brands they're a fantastic option for
those looking to save money for the next
month raycon will have a countdown to
Christmas with a new pop-up flash deal
for you to take advantage of every
single day so click the link in the
description box or go to buyeracon.com
forward slash not marked to get 15 off
site-wide with code holiday like I said
there will also be new pop-up deals
every day during raycon's countdown to
Christmas and I'll try to keep the
description box updated with the latest
offers but just so you know you can
always go to buy recon.com forward slash
not Mark to get the best deals available
on raycon
what's up Frieza now seeing as we've
only got one starter left to give the
90s treatment too we may as well see how
Ashley does with quaxley interestingly
Ashley said quaxley was the toughest one
she had worked on she said I wasn't too
sure about how to approach him because
adding more detail to him like the other
bird Pokemon of the generation just
wouldn't fit it wouldn't work with his
theme I took heavy inspiration from
fireface inside of but honestly at the
end of the day what made quaxi so hard
was his character theming just didn't
feel like something they would have done
in gen 1 a Pokemon themed after a kid
who loves to dance is such a fun idea
for a starter but it's really out of
place in gen 1 oddly enough I tried to
at least maintain his hair and pull the
proportions to be more subdued the
biggest change being the wings typically
bird wings in Generation 1 are fairly
detailed with sight of being an outlier
I did try to give him arms akin to
psyduck's but that felt absolutely wrong
quaxi is definitely a Pokemon meant for
newer generation art styles amazing work
Ashley and thank you so much for
participating in this video alright so
we've seen a lot of designs time to
close things out with vivinc and he has
something very special for us with this
one by drawing the entire evolutionary
line of frigid backs three Pokemon from
starting form to Middle form all the way
to the second evolution form which looks
incredible spoiler alert so let's get
this one started now while these three
guys are being drawn I think the
conclusion I came to regarding the
differences that exist between these two
diametrically opposed Generations are
far more subtle than you might think
this isn't of course to suggest that
Generation 1 and generation 9 don't have
design differences however I do
sincerely think that there are
measurable differences to these
Generations differences that don't imply
that one is better than the other but
just the Natural Evolution of a style
over the course of almost 30 years at
this point every long running series
undergo stylistic changes stemming from
that same root philosophy Ken tsukumori
one of the main artists behind the
original 150 still works on the designs
of the new Pokemon to this very day and
it really isn't unheard of for styles to
change with the culture and requirements
of the medium they are preparing for I
mean Akira Toriyama when he was drawing
Dragon Ball in the early 90s boasted
designs that looked exceptionally
different to that which he ended the
series with in the Buu saga these
changes came about both due to the
Natural Evolution of his tastes and due
to what the story demanded from him at
the time I can't personally speak to
what the Pokemon series needed to adapt
to with regards to game design though
it's obvious that the games have had to
undergo massive differences visually
over the last 25 years as they should
the point is as a series and story
develops the style which these
characters are drawn will inevitably
change whether it be through natural
stylistic progression as seen in Ken
tsugamori's designs or with slight
alterations to existing designs like
with the modern interpretation of the
Animaniacs which Ashley worked on
however concerning the images here
Vivint absolutely is killing it with
these redraws of these characters with
Bax caliber perhaps highlighting
something I personally didn't like about
the new games myself remember in the old
games when you'd look at your Pokedex
and the Pokemon and they'd be doing some
Dynamic pose that accentuated who those
Pokemon are well now they look I don't
know less Dynamic I mean back scale
developer in this game Avatar looks like
he's being called to the principal's
office like he's being scolded he's just
standing up at attention and this redraw
just really highlights that for me now
big thanks to both Ashley and Vivian for
their wonderful workout contributions to
this video their socials are in the
description if you want to see more from
them I do have two other redraws that
Vivint did actually but if you want to
see them you'll have to head over to my
Tick Tock at totally not Mark I've
posted one of these redraws already and
the next one will be going up tomorrow
I've been posting on Tick Tock all
weekend it's actually pretty fun it's an
easy way of me making shorter content
that doesn't always make it into videos
like this one for instance of me
correcting someone about their dragon
ball attack so if you'd like to see me
doing that or some of their Pokemon
designs feel free to check out my Tick
Tock I totally not Mark Link's in the
description in conclusion now that we've
seen a bunch of different modern Pokemon
redrawn and in the process learned a lot
about the design philosophy of not just
Pokemon but a host of other Series in a
similar position what's my takeaway well
earlier last week I posted two questions
to my Twitter the first being which
Pokemon generation had the best designs
and the second being which is the best
designed Pokemon and the responses to
those tweets just tell the story in a
nutshell you can certainly prefer one
over the other I personally do and I
think that's inevitable however the
mistake that people often make myself
included is that there's an objective
way to measure how great a design is
when there's not in this video I
highlighted one thing that the design
shapes used have indeed changed or
become or varied that is neither a good
nor a Bad Thing necessarily just a
difference unlike the slow changes
Dragon Ball experienced over its tenure
when it comes to generational releases
like Pokemon offers I think they live up
to their name there are of course
hundreds of thousands of you out there
who have played all of the games
throughout your lives but I'm also
certain that there are those that simply
aged out of the games around the third
generation and when they tried to pick
up them again for the modern stuff it
felt more alien to them than those that
aged up with them sort of like going
from the first three arcs of Dragon Ball
and plopping yourself into the middle of
Dragon Ball super it would of course
Force feel alien and feel entirely
different aesthetically and given the
cyclical nature of Pokemon itself in
that younger Generations tend to pick up
the newer games as their Gateway and
older fans tend to drop off from time to
time it stands to reason that the most
significant factor that dictates what
makes a Pokemon a Pokemon to someone is
an entirely personal experience the same
way someone who loves gen 1 might look
at jnade as something that's lost its
Edge someone who started with Gen 8
might just as rightly look at the past
in gen 1 and see something lacking that
which they identify as something
specifically Pokemon a few years ago I
made a pretty bad video about Pokemon
designs and while I do think there are
stylistic differences between the likes
of Generation 1 and generation 9. I
don't think this is always a bad thing
and far more subjective than others
might suggest it has nothing to do with
simpler shapes necessarily or how
animalistic other designs might appear
it doesn't have to do with how they are
all colored or even the philosophical
differences in approach certain
characters have been designed with I
think it's entirely down to how
differently the term Pokemon has been
defined in each of our individual Minds
informed by our first glimpses into the
series we all know and love for me it
was looking at that game cover of the
red version case with the classic design
of Charizard in 1998 but for some of my
friends it was seen someone playing
Pokemon Emerald on the playground or
seeing a generation a trading card the
best thing about Pokemon is the variety
it provides us with and in that same way
I think it should be okay to love and
appreciate what was and have fun
redesigning what currently is while
giving it the respect it deserves
I've been totally not Mark and thank you
so much for watching